just living your best life right now
yeah so look this is fun there's so many
people this is your first Met Gala right
people on here yes this is my first I'm
so distracted by everything it's like
squirrels everywhere you go you got
Michelle yo behind you then over here I
believe this is Kylie Jenner with the
Kardashians and Kylie's like just behind
me I feel like I should be more educated
on them I know nothing you know what you
could be my co-host we could you come
back here and help me do my job all
right Pedro's gonna be here tonight a
little review I really want to find him
um I think he's like coming up right now
I can't wait
I have no idea what they are but they're
really making my back hurt tonight hey
tell me this have you picked Pedro's
brain about being in Gladiator
good again he's being cast in the sequel
to Gladiator Pedro yes that's a little
dinner talk for you hey thank you thanks
so much
foreign
[Music]